peu
[Musique]
conférence de presse improvisée au
drugstore josé gérard son plus violent
et plus lucide mais il ne voit pas
pourquoi après tout ils n'aimeraient pas
aussi large
en france on vous sort toujours la même
formule les français nous avons sens du
ridicule c'est absolument stupide alors
ça englobe des tas de convention qui
sont absolument inconfortable on peut
pas vivre quoi c'est pas y'a aucune
liberté dans le fond
[Musique]
voilà que c'est vraiment rapide
non non le tas de choses
en france spécialement il ya des tas de
choses qui
je trouve les gens cons
l'opecst moins évolué qu'en angleterre
par leur esprit critique tout genre
[Musique]
stagner
non jamais rien vu pour eux tout partir
du moment où on a les cheveux longs et
raides les gens comprennent pas ils sont
bêtes ils sont content je suis pas
spécialement révolté il ya des choses
que je trouve exagérée ya déjà des vous
dirais-je d'aidé
toujours cette question ces remarques
l'art de mon temps c'était pas comme ça
c'est absolument faux puisque les les
gens qui ont maintenant mettons 40 ans
de ça ont connus ont été absous par
exemple à saint germain des prés il
avait aussi les cheveux longs et avait
une mode que tout le monde critique et
que leur père critique elle est donc
c'est un éternel recommencement toute
façon il n'y a pas besoin d'en faire un
drame on dirait les jeunes de maintenant
c'est pas vrai les jeunes de maintenant
ils font beaucoup moins de choses qui à
l'époque dans le fond absolument non
absolument pas autre heure on aime on
trouve absolument pas alors là moi
j'aime le concours quand je pars en
vacances il me faut une villa jamais
avoir à j'aime pas la plage avec tout le
monde j'ai ma absolument mon confort
avant tout ça soit on fait quelque chose
on
on n'est pas en eux on n'est pas des
glandeurs quoi si vous voulez
actuellement c'est différent les
intérieurs de verrès de vacances moi je
fais philo et après je vais faire je
vais faire sciences politiques
certainement mais toute façon on fait je
me suis absolument ma [ __ ] knicks
j'en
non
[Musique]
vous devez intéressé dans les politiques
français considèrent que je peux pas en
parler puisque ce moment interviewé par
que je veux pas m'en occuper j'aime plus
la france je vais partir de france
pourquoi les plus la fin à ce que je
n'aime pas la france je veux pas vivre
en france j'aime pas les français j'aime
pas la réaction des français j'aime pas
qu'est ce que vous leur reprochez je
leur reproche tout ça vous regarde et un
pays comme l'angleterre de petites
choses anodines par exemple en france en
tête à marcher sur les pelouses pourquoi
en angleterre on peut marcher sur les
pelouses on peut dormir sur les plus
pauvres on peut pas fumer dans le métro
dans les cinémas mais je comprends pas
on peut dépenser beaucoup d'argent ah
oui bon on attend important elodie
d'argent pour des jeunes ont dépensé
d'argent pourquoi importante c'est
important l'argent pour vous bien sûr
c'est important juge évidemment cette
impuissance
je ne suis pas l'idéaliste mois qui va
dire l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur
j'ai stupide pour moi l'argent fait le
bonheur sans argent on n'est rien à tout
le monde de gagner de l'argent tout le
monde se met en quatre pour pour avoir
un peu d'argent alors les gens qui me
sortent en sécurité d'une vie
matérialiste
moi j'en ai rien à [ __ ] moi je vois
sans argent je m'emmerde je suis parent
bien je ne suis pas heureux il faut
monter dans un show il me faut mais même
âme et mon petit steak tous les midis
moi j'aime ça et sans argent il y en a
pas non d'accord il faut de l'argent que
tout le monde sait qu'il faut de
l'argent fou comme les gens qui vont
vers le travail ça vous ennuie le
travail le travail et c'est à dire que
moi ce que je veux faire ce pas
exactement du travail c'est ce qui me
plaît
qu'est ce que c'est il vous plaît on
faire des courses automobiles
samedi absolument pas si c'est une
passion pour moi si je peux pas faire ça
je ferai rien d'autre qu il résout à
leur jeu sera indiqué sur serre
qu'est-ce que vous avez quelle sorte de
travaille moi ce que je veux et ce que
je vais c'est le printemps et par
exemple rémunéré je vous y connaître mon
patron si vous voulez moi j'aimerais un
certain travail de chercheur si vous
voulez dans un sens j'adore l'histoire
c'est ma passion
donc 10 recherche historique ça
m'intéresserait beaucoup la raison de
mettre des boules ans à 0 ça c'est pas
possible pour moi est ce que vous pensez
des gens qui sont obligés l'emmène je
les plains
[Musique]